President Trump has declared Hawaii's
Big Island a disaster zone as fears grow
about the lava and smoke from the Mount
Kilauea volcano the declaration clears
the way for financial assistance for
state and local governments to fix roads
parks and water pipes damaged by the
eruption at the same time geologists are
bracing for more destructive eruptions
Carter Evans reports from the Big Island
after more than a week of fiery
devastation scientists are now watching
and waiting for the volcano's next big
move
they say Kilauea has the potential to
produce a massive steam explosion at any
time unlike anything the Big Island has
seen in nearly a century
that's because lava is draining and the
summit crater and could soon mix with
groundwater Janet Babb is with the US
Geological Survey do people in the
surrounding communities have to worry
about boulders falling on their homes no
no not at all because the boulders will
only be carried in the immediate
vicinity of the event if there's an
explosion geologists say the largest
rocks would land in this area marble
sized rocks could fall up to a half mile
away but still within the closed
national park the resulting ash cloud
could be 20,000 feet high and blown
across the island ash fall is a nuisance
but it doesn't threaten life despite the
science behind the eruption most people
who live here believe there's more to it
according to hawaiian mythology Pele the
goddess of fire inhabits Kilauea and
controls the lava people leave offerings
to please her all over the island and
they accept her will Harry Kim is the
mayor of Hawaii County I feel like
people are very accepting it's when you
close to nature and you have to be
around here
you accept love leave up she's this part
of that there's a price for paradise it
was the place it really is a place
earthquakes and lava are a way of life
here in Hawaii Kilauea has been in a
constant state of eruption since 1983
during that time the entire community of
kalapana was wiped down so people here
are aware of this volcano's power and
they have a healthy dose of respect for
it for CBS this morning Saturday Carter
Evans the Big Island of Hawaii